The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
All right, so we're
going to start a new topic today
about ordinary differential
equations initial
value problems.
But before I start
to talk about that,
I want to remind you next
week's schedule is weird.
So there's no classes on
Monday, but instead we'll
have Monday class on Tuesday.
So I'll see you next
on Tuesday morning.
And then we're not going to
have a class on Wednesday,
but we have the quiz
on Wednesday night.
And then we'll get back
to normal on Friday.
And I would expect that
possibly the TAs might
be interested in giving a help
session or review on Wednesday
the class period.
AUDIENCE: We'll be here at 3:00.
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
They'll be here.
So if you want to
come at class period,
and just ask
questions and stuff.
AUDIENCE: And I'll have your
PSAT graded back, if you like.
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
All right, got that?
PSAT be ready as well.
OK, so I'll talk
about today ODE-IVPs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we'll still have
office hours Monday [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Can
you guys hear this?
Yes, office hours
like normal Monday.
And for those of you who
want to get your homework
started early, we might
even post homework.
And I'm going to focus
exclusively on ODE-IVPs
you can write this way.
All right, and I
would just comment,
what do these things mean?
ODE means ordinary
differential equation.
It means that the only
differentials in the problem
are with respect
to one variable,
so I'm going to call that t.
It can be z or x or
whatever you want,
but I'm going to call it t here.
And so this is not partial
differential equations
where you have differentials
respect to many variables.
Initial value problems mean
that all the initial conditions
are given in at a
single t point where
t is that the variable that
appears in the differential.
All right so this is the
form we're going to do.
This is first order a
way of writing the ODEs.
If you recall from homework
zero problem number one,
we showed you there how you can
write higher order differential
equations--
convert them into the
form of first order.
And I guess that's
worthwhile to point down.
I would also comment
that I going to just talk
about f of y, however
the ODE solvers in Matlab
expect f of the t
comma y as their from.
All right, so let's just explain
all the details about this.
So suppose I had a differential
equation like this.
All right, so this is like a
differential equation you'd
have for a body move moving--
a particle moving with
some friction force on it
and some time varying force.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you going to
be posting your notes online?
WILLIAM GREEN JR: No,
I don't have any notes.
This is it.
All right, so this is a
differential equation.
What you can do is to convert
it into the form I have above,
is to write a new variable, say
v, that's defined to be dx dt.
That's the velocity.
And has a time
dependence, but I told you
I don't like time
dependence, so I'm not
going to write it that way.
So we can also define
another variable.
So we can define our new y
vector to be x, v, and t.
So this is y-- the
first component of y,
this is the second
component of y,
this is the third
component of y.
And then I can write
down what f of y is.
So the equation for dx dt is y2.
It's the second component
of y, dx dt is equal to v.
The equation for the dv dt
is given by this equation.
So that's f of y3
over m minus gamma y2.
And the equation
dt dt is just one.
So this is my f of y.
So this is f1, f2, f3.
Is that all right?
So this is just how
you can convert--
if somebody writes you
an equation this way,
and you want to get it into the
standard form that I'm going
to show you here--
dy dt equals f of y--
this is how you convert.
And a skill we haven't
really emphasized so far
in the course, but I think
a very important skill,
is to be able to get like a
chemical engineering problem
and rearrange it so it
becomes a standard form
that maps up to one of the
solvers you know how to use.
So you've got a problem has
some differential in it.
Right away you actually,
can I somehow rewrite it
so it looks like this standard
form-- or actually for Matlab,
this form.
So Matlab will say f of t, y.
If you can do that, then you can
go ahead and use those Matlab
solvers to solve it.
But your variables may not have
a letter y appearing anywhere,
right?
You have to figure
out how to write it
into the standard form.
And then once you can do
that, you can use the solvers.
And the same thing
with the non-linear
equations solvers, with
the optimization software.
If you can rewrite
it into the form that
matches the standard form, then
once you're done, you're done.
Then you can just go and
call the canned programs
that work well for those forms.
All right, now what do
we want as the output?
So this is the problem.
This is the problem as proposed.
What do we really
want out of this?
What we're going to get out
of it is a bunch of points y--
actually a matrix, right?
It would be a
vector of y-values.
Typically y is a vector.
And we want to know it
a bunch of time points.
And we would a
lot of time points
so we're getting pretty plots
of how the components of y
vary with time.
That's what we usually want.
Sometimes we just want the
final value, y time value.
We integrate to some point
and then stop, and just
run through the final value.
But a lot of times, we actually
want to make pretty plots,
so we really want a lot of
points here and making plots.
Now how many points do you
need to make a nice plot?
Maybe, I don't know,
100 points, 50 points,
you can make a nice plot.
So that's the kind
numbers you'd like.
And so the output
of these programs
is going to be something like
a vector of the time points,
and then a matrix of the
y-values corresponding
to each time point.
And the way it does in
that lab, it's reasonable.
Each row of y are
the y-values that
correspond to the same time
point, the first time point.
So the first row of y
corresponds to the first number
in the time vector.
The second run is the second.
Last one will be at time final.
And then you can plot them.
OK so far?
And ideally, we would like
these y-values that we compute,
these y's we get
out, ideally one
that really close to
what the true solution
of the true differential
equation is.
But we're doing numerical
stuff, so it's never
going to be exactly the same.
And so a big part of the
effort is trying to figure out,
how can we get the thing
to compute y calculated
at each time point
to be as close
as possible to the truth,
of what the true solution
of the equations are?
And that turns out
to be difficult,
so that's a very important
thing to worry about.
What else can we say about this?
We specify this from t naught,
and you typically have to input
your t final, how far you want
to go away from your t naught
as another input.
Normally, people write it where
t naught is less than t final,
and so you're like integrating
from left to right.
But you could actually write
them, put a negative sign
equation which corresponds
to a negative t,
change your variable
to of t prime that
was equal to t final
minus t if you wanted to,
and integrate the
other direction.
And in fact in homework zero
problem one, we did that too.
So you can integrate frontwards.
You can integrate backwards.
If somebody tells you the
initial condition or condition
in the center of the range,
you integrate forward
for part of the range, and
backwards the other way,
so anything like this.
So what's important
for this to be
what's called an initial
value problem is just
that all of the
specifications of y
are given at the
same value of t.
It doesn't matter exactly
what value of t it is.
Later, we'll talk
about what happens
if you don't know all
the specifications at one
value of time.
All right, now how
would you approach this?
Probably, a bunch of you've done
this already as undergraduates,
or maybe even high school.
You can write like
a Taylor expansion,
y of t plus delta t--
is y of t plus delta t--
times dy dt.
You can write that.
And then I say,
wow, I know dy dt.
That's actually f, so this
is actually equal to--
right?
And then if I truncate
the Taylor expansion,
now I have an update formula.
So if I just forget
this last bit,
I can put in my current value of
y, like the initial condition.
The initial condition
here, evaluate f,
multiply by delta t,
add them together,
and I'll get a new value of y.
And then I can repeat
over and over again.
And in fact, this is
a very famous method.
It's called the
Forward Euler method.
Euler was a pretty smart guy, so
it's not completely ridiculous,
but as I'll show you,
it has some problems.
So the Forward Euler, another
way to write it is y new
is equal to y old plus
delta t times f of y old.
It's called Forward Euler.
And we can write a little
implementation of this
pretty easily.
So you can write y
is equal to y naught,
t is equal to t
naught for i equals 1
to the number of
steps, y is equal to y
plus delta t times f of y, t
is equal to t plus delta t.
Somewhere up here, I
need to write delta t.
OK, so there's your code
for doing Forward Euler.
How many of you have
done this before?
OK, so I can skip
over this very fast.
How many did this, and it
didn't work for a problem?
OK, so you're not doing
hard enough problems.
Well, we'll correct that.
All right, so I noticed
that this closely
resembles the rectangle rule.
So the rectangle rule
would look a lot the same.
However, if you're
integrating a function--
so I have I is equal to
the integral of f of t dt,
then I can notice
that the derivative dI
dt is equal to f of t.
And so if I was going to
do the rectangle rule,
it would look just the same as
this, except this would be a t.
Maybe I would pick y0 to be 0.
And the final value
of y I would get to
would be my integral,
my i value that I want.
So how many of you have
done rectangle rule?
Yes?
All right, so you
did this already.
Now you remember in high school,
when they took the rectangle
rule, they probably mentioned
that it's not very accurate.
And so then they also
taught you some other ones.
You guys, how many of you
learned the trapezoid rule?
How about the midpoint rule?
How about Simpson's rule?
All right, so at least a
high school math teachers
thought that this is
inadequate for doing real work,
so they tell you all these
other things instead.
This was like your
first baby thing.
So let's talk
about why was that.
So let's do the Taylor
expansion a little bit further.
So let's do it for the
numeric [INAUDIBLE] case.
So y t plus delta t is equal
to y of t plus delta t times
f of t plus 1/2 delta t squared
times the second derivative.
And so when we made
the approximation
to do the rectangle rule, we
just threw this term away.
So that's a leading
term that we threw away.
So we made an error
order or delta t squared.
Because normally the second
derivative is not exactly zero.
So we have an error
in each step that's
the order of delta t squared.
But how many steps do we make?
The number of steps is
equal to t final minus t
naught over delta t.
So therefore, we're making
one over delta t order steps.
So the total error is going
to be approximately the number
of steps times how much
error you making each step.
So it's going to be something
the second power in delta t
divided by something to
the first power of delta t.
So the total error
in the integral I
is going to be older of delta
t if you do the rectangle rule.
And so order delta
t is not very good.
So you want to increase
your accuracy--
if you cut your
step size in half,
that means you
double your CPU time,
because you have to do twice
as many function evaluations.
But you only gain-- you reduce
your error by a factor of two.
So if you want to, say, gain
three significant figures
of accuracy in your
number, then you
have to do 1,000 times much
work as you did before.
So I have some amount
of some precision
with some number of steps.
I want to increase, get three
more significant figures.
I'll have to do 1,000
times as much work.
That's kind of bad scaling.
If I want to get six
more significant figures,
I've got to do a
million times more work.
So at some point, this going
to be kind of expensive.
So if you contrast it, you can
do things like trapezoid rule.
And as you're probably--
well let's talk about
trapezoid rule for a bit.
So the idea of this is
you have your function,
you have some point
t, and t plus delta t.
You're trying to
integrate between them.
Let's say t naught, t
naught plus delta t.
Try to integrate.
Here's the value of
the function at t.
Here is the value of the
function that t plus delta t.
If you do the rectangle
rule, what you say
is I just draw a line here
and integrate that rectangle.
But say the real function
really looks like this.
Then I missing that area
there, so that's the error.
That's why the error's so big.
If I do that trapezoid
rule, then the error--
I actually overestimate
the value here,
but the integral
of the difference
between this dotted
line and the solid line
is less than the integral
between the solid line
and that dotted line,
so its more accurate.
So that's why people
like the trapezoid rule
better than the rectangle rule.
If you did the
midpoint rule, you'd
evaluate this function halfway
between these two points
and then draw a dotted line
here and a dotted line there,
and integrate that guy.
And it would
overestimate for part,
and underestimate for part,
and they would partially
cancel each other out.
And so that also would be
more accurate than doing
the rectangle rule.
So you did it before.
And so what we're
going to try to do
is, instead of
using this formula
we did before, we're going to
replace this with something
else that I'm going to call g.
And g is something
that's supposed
to be the average value
of f over the step.
Instead of just taking the
value f at the starting point,
I want to get sort
of the average.
Right, because an
integral is related
to an average over the delta t.
So g is going to be my way
to estimate the average.
And there's going to
be a zillion update
formulas that different
mathematicians have
proposed over the years.
They give you different g's that
tell you how to do the update.
And the key is try to find
a g that's really accurate.
You want to have one that's
the most accurate you can,
because then your
errors will be less.
And if your errors are
less, than your delta t can
be bigger, which means your
number of steps will be less,
which means your CPU
time will be less.
So you might be able
to get more accuracy
and use less CPU
time both if you
can find a really good
formula for g, for the update.
So what's the g for
the trapezoid rule?
It's f of t plus f of
t plus delta t over 2.
That was the g you used when
you did the trapezoid rule when
you were kids.
What is the g for
the midpoint rule?
It's f of t plus delta t over 2.
And so the different g's
are called different update
formulas.
And these particular
ones reduce the error
from delta t squared for
[INAUDIBLE] step to, I think,
delta t to the cubed power.
And then when you multiply
by this 1 every delta t,
it turns out you go from
being order of delta t
to order of delta t squared,
and that's a really big change.
So now if I cut the step
size by a factor of 10,
I gain a factor of
100 in the accuracy.
If I want to get six
more significant figures,
I do 1,000 times more work,
not a million times more work.
So it's a pretty
significant improvement.
And then people have pushed
this on further and further.
And so actually very
common integrators
that you might use
nowadays would go out
to fourth and fifth
order methods.
And so they have
complicated update formulas
that are carefully
designed to cancel out
all the low order delta t errors
and just leave very high order
ones.
And that's kind of the--
typical ones are like that.
And then some fancy ones might
go even up to eighth order,
I've seen, if you're
really pushing it.
You have really complicated
g formulas then.
Now, this is all
for the integration,
but really our problem was
that the ODEs [INAUDIBLE]..
So we have to do
f of y not f of t.
Let's see if I
can show you that.
Yeah, so we did the rectangle
rule, we had f of t.
But the real problem is
we have to do f of y.
Now the problem
is, we don't know
what y is, y is our unknown.
So we generally
have a problem here.
In Forward Euler, we can get
away with it because we just
put the y old value in.
Like for example, if we
wanted to do midpoint here,
we'd have to know f at
a different time point
that we haven't computed yet,
because it's forward in time.
Same thing with
trapezoidal rule.
We have to know f at
some future timepoint.
So it's not so easy,
actually, to go directly
from these formulas to some
explicit formula like this
with a g in here, where
the things inside g,
the y's inside g, are all
y-values we actually know.
So this is a serious problem.
But this didn't stop
people from doing it.
So one idea is you could go
back to the Taylor expansion,
and now do the Taylor expansion
but in terms of f of y.
So this is f of y of t.
And then over here, this
is d squared y dt squared,
but dy dt is f, so
this is really df dt.
But f is actually not a function
of t, it's a function of y,
right?
But we can do chain rule.
So df dt is equal to
the sum df dyn dyn dt.
But dyn dt is f.
And this is what we call
the Jacobian [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is really saying that
this is equal to J times f.
So that would be
one possibility,
is you could go and write
the Taylor expansion
out to the next higher
order explicitly,
putting in J times f
here, and then just
being in the cubic terms.
Now, people don't
do this usually.
Any idea why this is not
a popular thing to do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's computationally
expensive to [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM GREEN JR: That's right.
That's right.
So how many function
evaluations does it
take to get the Jacobian?
Right, so each function
is n values, right,
because it's a vector.
And you have to do at least,
say, forward differences
would be n function evaluations.
So instead of just doing
one function evaluation
like we were doing with
the Forward Euler, now
we have to do n plus 1,
or something like that,
function evaluations.
And actually, you probably
want to use center differences,
so you need 2 times n plus 1.
And if you do them analytically,
unless it's sparse,
it's still going to be really
expensive to compute it.
So it's a lot more
effort to do it.
So you need to think, well,
is it really worth it?
And so people have found
other formulas that basically
get rid of the delta
t squared term that
don't require so much
effort, and so that's
what people do instead.
But this is an option.
You could do it.
All right, so
instead, what people
do is they've decided to
generalize the midpoint rule
and try to figure
out, how can we
get an estimate of the midpoint
value that's cheap to evaluate?
And so what they
say is, well, this
is g midpoint for
numerical integration.
Let's make an new g
midpoint that works
for when f is a function of y.
So let's make it
function of y evaluated
at t plus delta t over 2.
So that's what the
formula looks like.
But then you say,
well, I don't know
y is at t plus delta t
over 2, because I only
know it at y of t.
So then they say, well, let's
do Forward Euler for that.
say it's approximately f of--
what's the Forward
Euler formula?
It's y of t plus delta t
over 2 times f of y of t.
How many parenthesis there?
So this is the formula
that's actually
used in practice a lot.
And this one is called
Runge-Kutta two, second order
Runge-Kutta formula.
And it's just a--
it's the midpoint rule where
we estimate the value of y of t
plus delta t using
Forward Euler.
And the advantage of this
is it's very cheap, right?
Just evaluate-- I just have
to evaluate one function here,
one function here, so
two function calls.
[INAUDIBLE] and that way I
can get an update formula.
And this one, turns out
that it has the nice delta t
scaling that you might like.
So that's the kind
of thing people do.
And the Runge-Kutta
guys went crazy,
and so one of the
most popular solvers
is called Runge-Kutta four five,
and that's the ODE four five
program in Matlab.
And what that does is the
fourth order extension of this,
and the fifth order
extension of this.
And it uses them both,
and it compares them,
and uses the difference
between an estimate the error
in the calculation.
And then uses that to decide
what size delta t you need,
depending on what
tolerances you demand.
And the formulas for all those--
[INAUDIBLE] formulas are
given in the textbook.
Now, this starts to
lead the problem.
So we weren't able to actually
evaluate the true g midpoint,
which we'd like to be here.
Instead, we have to use
some approximation in order
to extrapolate
forwards to the y.
So this is hinting
at the whole problem.
This whole problem is actually
we're just extrapolating.
We know the true value
of y only at t naught,
and all the rest we're doing
is extrapolating forwards.
And we're do it
over and over again,
so we're going to
do it for n steps.
Maybe we'll do 1,000 steps.
So you're extrapolating.
And then based on
that extrapolation,
you going to extrapolate again.
And then based on extrapolation,
And you can see that this is
not really the most robust thing
to do, right?
Because if you have
any experience,
you're not that comfortable
extrapolating at all.
And then you have to
extrapolate 1,000 times.
You should be a little bit
worried about what can happen.
So let's think about how
the error will propagate.
So we're going to have
some errors while we
do these extrapolations.
So we have here a t naught,
t naught, we're happy.
We know y naught.
This is exact.
We're like woohoo.
We know one value
of y, really good.
All right, so now the
question is the first step.
Now we're going
to get to value y1
that we compute with
one of the formulas,
and it's going to be
good to some accuracy
depending on how good or
g is, our update formula.
And so it's going
to have an error.
I should comment
that this y naught,
although we treat it as exact,
it could have an error too.
But it will probably be more
like a machine precision
kind of error because
we don't really
know the initial
conditions that well.
Or might be an
experimental error
about how well we know what
the initial conditions are.
But I'm not going to worry
about that one for now.
But be aware, this is
true, we don't really
know initial conditions
perfectly either.
But certainly, even if we treat
this as being known perfectly,
we're going to have some error
by the time we extrapolate
to y1.
So now what happens at y2?
So now we've added some
more, so now we're at t2.
And we see started from
y1 true plus some error.
This is y-- y naught was true.
Now we're starting from y1
true with some error in it,
because of a mistake
we made the first step.
And now we see how that
step propagates further.
So let's see what
that's going to say.
Well say y2 is going to
equal y1 plus delta t times
some update formula
which would depend on y1.
But y1 was not true
anymore, so this is actually
equal to what should have
been the true value of y1
if we only knew what it
was, but we don't know.
And we have our error that
we don't know exactly how
big it is that we added on.
And then we have another
term from this guy,
so it's going to
be delta t times
g of y1 true plus delta 1.
And then we know our update
formula's not right anyway,
so there's actually
another error, delta 2,
just because of the error
in the update formula.
Now if we had a
great update formula,
these deltas are kind of small.
And if somehow, by
luck, our delta 1 was 0,
and we had a great
update formula,
then we think that this error in
y2 is going to be pretty small.
But it's not true.
So really the errors
are pretty big.
So let's see if we
can figure out--
we're going to do a
Taylor expansion here,
so this'll be g of
y1 true plus d dgy--
the Jacobian of g
with respect to y--
times the delta 1.
That's the first order
Taylor extension.
All right, so now
let's group the terms.
So y2 is equal to y1 true
plus the update formula of y1
true plus the error
in our update formula
if we had started
at the true value.
So this is what we--
if somebody told us what
the true value of y1, this
is the size error we'd expect.
It's to be that little
error we calculated before.
But then on top of it, we
have these other terms.
We have a delta 1, because
y1 was not the true value.
Sorry, I lost a delta t here.
And then we have delta t
times dg dy times delta 1.
And I'll emphasize
these are all vectors.
I think that's it if we
only keep to first order.
So what is this thing?
This is a matrix, right, dg dy.
I could write it this way.
It's the identity matrix plus
delta t times the Jacobian dg
dy times the vector d1.
And you can see, at every
iteration when I do this,
I'm going to get a
similar factor like this.
And it's going to
again multiply delta 1.
I keep on multiplying the--
errors from my
previous step keep
getting multiplied by
this kind of factor.
So it's going to be
really important to us
about what the norm
of this matrix is.
What's going to happen if the
normal of this matrix is big?
What's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: That's
right, the error's going
to get multiplied
by some factor,
say bigger than 1,
every iteration.
And after we go 1,000
iterations, how big
is the error going to be?
Really big, right?
Even if that thing is quite
close to 1, 1 plus something
to the 1,000 power
it's gigantic.
So what was originally
a pretty small error--
because we chose
a good g method--
is going to get multiplied by
this huge amplification factor.
So the key thing
for a method to be
what is called
numerically stable
is that the norm of this matrix
has got to be less than 1.
Or maybe even equal,
equals 1 might be OK.
If this is much bigger
than 1, you're doomed.
Your numeric order is
just going to blow up
from step to step to step.
And what's bad about it,
is actually sometimes
you might not even
be aware of this.
So you'll get some solution,
because it still will calculate
some numbers for the y's at
each type-- y1, y2, y3, y4--
it's just running
through the calculation.
But the numbers may become
increasingly meaningless
further away from the y true as
time goes on, as the steps go.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Yes, it can.
Yeah, so that's what we call a
stable numerical method is one
that, if you make an
error in an earlier step,
its impact diminishes
as the steps go on.
That's what you want.
You can't always achieve this.
But if you can,
that's really great.
Then that's you would call
a really stable, robust kind
of method.
Even though I give you
some stupidity early on,
my stupidity
evaporates away, and it
goes to the true solution.
That's what you want.
OK, so let's think of
cases where it's going
to be problematic for sure.
So if dg dy--
say if all it's
eigenvalues are positive
and you add it to
identity matrix,
the thing is still going to
have eigenvalues bigger than 1.
Can you see that?
And actually, what do we
say when dg dy is positive,
has a positive eigenvalue?
You guys have a word
for this already
you learn in your
differential equations class.
What do you call these kind
of differential equations?
Maybe not dg dy.
Back up, how about df dy?
If df dy, if that Jacobian
has a positive eigenvalue,
what do you say?
You guys remember this?
So this is what we call
unstable differential equations.
So if it has any
positive eigenvalues,
then two initial conditions that
differ by a little differential
exponentially separate
as time goes on as long
as the difference as any
projection in the direction
of the bad eigenvector.
So those are called
numerically unstable.
A lot of those actually
exist in reality.
So explosions,
that's because you
had some positive eigenvalue
somewhere for example.
Amplifiers, like
you buy an amplifier
to crank up the music, you
get positive feedback when--
remember Professor Swan
walked to some strange place,
and for some reason, he got
the feedback from the speakers?
So he had a positive
eigenvalue going there.
A little tiny noise and
his microphone, and it
amplified to a big squeak.
So there are real systems
like this that amplify.
And sometimes we
want to model them,
like explosions for examples.
That's a pretty important
for chemical engineers.
But it's going to be really
tough, because if it's
got positive eigenvalues,
then this is probably going
to have a norm bigger than 1.
And then whatever
little errors we
may get any step in
the whole calculation,
we're going to amplify
and amplify and amplify.
And who knows if
we're going to have
any reality left in our solution
by the time we get to the end.
All right, so that's
one kind of problem.
So how about we have a problem
that's intrinsically stable.
That means that
all the eigenvalues
of the Jacobian of the
original problem are negative.
So the thing should
be perfectly stable.
From whatever initial
condition they started from,
the whole thing should
sort of come down
to like an equilibrium point.
So that's a pretty
common situation
in chemical engineering too.
You start from some
state, and it relaxes down
to like an equilibrium
state or a steady state.
Well-behaved systems
act like that.
So what I'm going
to show you is that,
despite the fact that the
df dy is well-behaved,
it's possible that this
sum matrix might still
be poorly behaved and still
have a norm bigger that one.
And so that means you
started for a problem that
was pretty well-behaved, and
you broke it by your choice
in numerical method.
So this is a very bad one.
This is the kind that can
make you really embarrassed
if you're working in a company.
Your boss gives you a problem.
He says, please tell me the time
is going to take our reactor
to relax after a start up.
the system is
perfectly well-behaved.
He gives these
beautiful equations
that your previous
coworker worked out.
Everything's fine.
You put it in there.
You use your stupid
numerical solver,
and you get a wild oscillation,
and the thing blows up.
OK, and that's going to be
because of a poor choice of g
so that it makes this norm of
this matrix bigger than one.
It's pretty easy
for that to happen.
So you don't need a very
complicated case to show it.
So let's just do a scalar case.
Say dy dt is equal
to negative 2y.
So this is a well-behaved
differential equation.
What's the solution?
So with a y naught y at
t equals 0 is equal to 1.
What's the solution?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
Yeah, OK, so it's
perfectly well-behaved function.
And the plot when you
plot it, here's one.
It goes [PLANE DIVING NOISE].
So now let's solve this with
the Forward Euler method.
So I'm going to say
that y new is equal to y
plus delta t times f.
So in this case, this is f,
right there, negative 2y.
So for Forward
Euler, this is just
saying that this is negative 2y.
All right, so let's
choose a delta t,
say delta t equals
1 to start with.
So we're going to compute.
We start at t equals 0.
We're computing out to t
equals 1. so we're out here.
So we put 1 in here.
Our initial condition
was y was 1, so that's 1.
So as 1 times negative
2 times 1 is negative 2.
This is a 1.
1 minus 2 is negative 1.
So at the first step, it
goes from here down to there.
This is not looking good.
This physical
variable is supposed
to be gradually
relaxing towards 0.
Going negative is
not what you want.
And then I think we could go
the next step, if you want.
So we can put in
suppose y is negative 1.
And we're still doing
a delta t of one step.
So negative 1 times
negative 2 is positive 2.
Plus negative 1, so this goes
back to the starting point.
We'll get the sawtooth,
is what you get.
And it turns out, actually,
if you make delta t any larger
than 1, then this
sawtooth amplifies,
so you have a oscillating
solution that explodes.
Which is a little bit different
than the physical solution,
which gently relaxes.
And so this is just
a scalar equation
that you guys could have
done in high school.
If you high school math
teacher had been brave,
he would have showed it you.
But he don't want to ruin your
faith in the Forward Euler
method, so he just showed you
a simple one that worked out.
Now you can make
this work better
by making the delta t smaller.
If you made the delta
t small enough--
in this case, I think it's
delta t is less than half--
then this actually behaves
somewhat reasonably.
And so what's going on there
is that the identity matrix
is positive.
My Jacobian is negative.
And if I make delta
t small enough,
this big positive number
is bigger than this smaller
negative number, and the
whole thing stays positive
but less than 1, and so
then the normal is good.
But if I make delta
t too large, I
make this second
term much larger.
If it gets much larger than 1,
it overwhelms the first term.
The thing's negative, but I
what do the norm it's positive.
And so it has an expansion.
Then the negative is why
we get these oscillations.
So if you ever do a numerical
differential equation solution
and you start seeing
this kind of stuff,
it's almost certainly related
to this numerical instability
of the method.
and not really a physical thing.
I mean, there are
physical things
that do this, but not too
often in chemical engineering,
fortunately.
All right, questions?
No questions, OK.
So in the textbook, they
have a big discussion
about how to evaluate
different g methods in order
to figure out if they're
guaranteed to be stable,
or under what conditions
they'll be stable.
And so that's worth
a look to see.
And they have
detailed derivations
for several of them.
Questions?
All right, so for the
homework, homework four,
you're going to have to
write your own ODE solver.
So you'll do update
formulas and compare them.
When we come back
on Tuesday, I'll
show you how this
is usually dealt
with by switching to implicit
solvers and talk about that.
All right, have a good weekend.
Enjoy the three days off.